it earned him respect from critics
invites to award shows and even an offer
to beat up some Nazis it also might be
his best movie this is how Punch Drunk
Love changed Adam Sandler forever Punch
Drunk Love writer director Paul Thomas
Anderson was a fan of Adam Sandler for
years before they ever collaborated
there was one sketch in particular
during Sandler's time as a cast member
on Saturday Night Live that really stood
out to him it was called the Denise show
and it featured his future leading man
as a lovelorn guy named O'Brien hosed a
talk show dedicated to his ex-girlfriend
his performance veers from mopy
heartbreak to White Hot rage whenever
Brian's father berates him for
embarrassing the family as Anderson told
Roger Ebert in 2002 honest to God I saw
this moment where it appears the whites
of his eyes turned black and they roll
back in his head I would play it back
over and over again Nicole Kidman
appeared in an installments of the
Denise show when she hosted SNL in 1993
her then husband Tom Cruz hung around
the studio that week and became friend
friendly with the cast including Sandler
years later while filming Magnolia Cruz
played Matchmaker by calling up Sandler
and putting Anderson on the phone the
young director expressed his desire to
write a role for Sandler and Sandler
gave his Blessing without much thought
but when Magnolia came out the prospect
of this collaboration suddenly became
slightly more intimidating as Sandler
recalled thinking on the smart L podcast
in 2020 I'm going to ruin his movie
released in 1999 Magnolia is a sprawling
3-hour epic about a group of disperate
Los Angeles residents to put it another
way it was about as far as possible from
what Adam Sandler's happy Madison
production company was putting out
during the same time so the thought of
working with Paul Thomas Anderson was
understandably daunting for Sandler when
Anderson delivered the punch drunk love
script to Sandler he talked him through
his hesitations the film is much smaller
in scope than Magnolia and while the
plot takes several unexpected turns
Sandler's character Barry Egan is in
many ways a kindred spirit to Happy guil
Filmore or the water boys Bobby buet
with his quiet loneliness interrupted by
bursts of violent rage Barry isn't so
much a departure from Sandler's typical
Persona as a refinement it's as if one
of those Happy Madison characters
wandered off the screen and ended up in
the Indie drama Next Door by 2002 Adam
Sandler had built a familiar company of
regular collaborators under the Happy
Madison Banner but on punch drunk love
he was in a different world with people
he wasn't used to working with meanwhile
Paul Thomas Anderson had his own
reparatory players both behind the
scenes and in front of the camera
including Luis Guzman and Philip Seymour
Hoffman Emily Watson was a new
collaborator for both Anderson and
Sandler and even 20 years later the idea
of them's romantic interests still seems
in congruous but despite his silly
reputation at the time Sandler impressed
her with his work ethic and commitment
as she put it during a 2022 interview he
is the most amazing generous hardworking
actor he turns up every day and is
really wonderful to work with there are
moments in the film where I am sitting
on my hands pinching myself laughing and
you can see Anderson felt much the same
way telling Roger eert in 2002 we have a
really similar work ethic kind of
obsessed and consumed by it and also I
wanted to learn from him about his
attack on stuff how does he make his
movies what are his concerns Philip
Seymour Hoffman was one of Paul Thomas
Anderson's company players from the very
beginning having appeared in his early
films hard8 Boogie Nights and Magnolia
in Punch Drunk Love he plays Dean a
mattress store manager in Utah who also
operates a phone sex line with a side
hustle and credit card theft and
extortion Dean's intensity stands in
sharp contrast to Barry's meekness
Hoffman and Adam Sandler don't share
much screen time since their characters
mostly communicate by phone but Anderson
made sure to have them on set together
while filming those scenes the two
actors had actually met years earlier
when Hoffman auditioned for a role in
Billy Madison only to turn it down after
Sandler offered it to him they
ultimately became friends during the
punch drunk love rehearsal process
Hoffman's energy even reminded Sandler
of another close friend of his his SNL
castmate Chris Farley who died in 1997
of a drug overdose at the age of 33
sadly Hoffman's similarities with Farley
didn't end with a Fearless intensity as
he also died of a drug overdose in 2014
at the age of 46 Punch Drunk Love
premiered to Acclaim at the can film
festival in May 2002 Sandler eventually
received a Golden Globe nomination and
by far the best reviews of his career
though often begrudgingly The Observers
Andrew Saras for one praised his
performance while also admitting I have
never considered myself one of Adam
Sandler's greatest admirers newsweek's
David ansen affectionately dubbed the
film unhappy Gilmore while entertainment
weeklys Owen gber declared Adam Sandler
removes the quote marks from his famous
personality and he's utterly winning to
watch
I sometimes cry a lot
L for no reason not every critic was
wowed but overall the critical consensus
was that after nearly a decade of
stardom Sandler not only had artistic
Ambitions but also had the chops to pull
them off this didn't suddenly turn him
into an indie darling though after the
high of punch drunk love he and the
critics went back to their normal
somewhat antagonistic routine of
Sandler's next five starring roles four
were Happy Madison Productions with an
average Rotten Tomato score and in the
low 40s and a combined box office gross
of nearly $600
million Adam Sandler's performance in
Punch Drunk Love was a revelation not
just to critics and audiences but also
to other directors since then he's
worked with the likes of James L Brooks
Jason wman and Noah balback but the
filmmakers he hasn't worked with are
arguably even more intriguing Quenton
Tarantino actually had a cameo in
Sandler's 2000 comedy Little Nikki and
pitched him a World War II Revenge
fantasy in which he would play a Jewish
American Soldier killing Nazis with a
baseball bat that would eventually
become the 2009 film in glorious
bastards unfortunately Sandler was
already committed to starring and funny
people so Tarantino cast Eli Roth
instead it's a testament to the power of
Sandler's turn in punch drunk love that
it still inspires admiration from
filmmakers decades later when Todd field
was on the promotional tour for his 2022
film tar he took a moment on the happy
sad confused podcast to gush about sand
as he declared it floored me it really
is one of the great screen performances
for me of all time I hope we end up
working together I really do we've been
talking about some things it's too early
to say one of the most striking things
about Sandler's filmography post Punch
Drunk Love is how few dramatic roles
he's taken on since then that's not
exactly surprising though while his
comedies are reliably popular with his
loyal audiences his attempts at drama
have been far more hit or miss his
performances in 2004 Spanglish and
2007's rainover me for example were well
received but the films themselves
endured their fair share of criticism
then 2009's funny people directed by Jud
appow cast Sandler as a movie star
re-evaluating his life and career after
a cancer diagnosis it offers an
interesting exploration of the world of
upand cominging comedians but otherwise
its critical reception was mixed at best
don't make me suffer please kill me IRA
despite those bumps Sandler's dramatic
roles in the first decade after Punch
Drunk Love were largely well-received
alas the same can't be said for a pair
of outright disasters that were released
in 2014 men women and children directed
by Jason wman strives to be a cautionary
tale about the negative influence of the
internet and social media but comes off
as a little hysterical later that year
though Sandler somehow outdid himself
with the cobbler directed by Tom
McCarthy it's a fable about a Shoemaker
who can can step into the lives of other
people McCarthy would actually go on to
write and direct the best picture wining
Spotlight the following year but the
cobbler was an absolute disaster among
critics and at the box office it took
Adam Sandler a while to receive the same
level of Acclaim for one of his dramatic
roles that he earned with punch drunk
love in 2017 he received strong notices
for the Noah bowback directed Ensemble
piece the mywit stories new and selected
and then his fortunes really improved 2
years later with cut gems the crime
Thriller written and directed by Josh
and Benny safy Sandler plays Howard
Ratner a diamond Merchant and gambler
whose constant search for the next big
score symbolized by a rare and Priceless
opal has alienated everyone in his life
that includes his wife his mistress and
even NBA superstar Kevin Garnett who
played himself the role was quite the
departure for Sandler but it also felt
like a culmination of everything he'd
done up to that point like Paul Thomas
Anderson the safy brothers were fans of
Sandler's work and wrote their script
with him in mind Sandler's manager
initially rejected the script in the
late 2000s but after several years of
changing hands Sandler came on board in
2018 the film was a critical success and
with a $50 million take at the box
office it was also Sandler's highest
grossing dramatic work since funny
people he went on to win the film
independent Spirit Award for best male
lead and also pretty much jumpstarted
the goldplated Furby Market this is how
I went while Adam sand initially seemed
hesitant to follow up punch drunk love
with more dramas his perspective seems
to have changed a bit in the 2020s he
and his uncut jams co-star Adena Menzel
have already reunited as onscreen
husband and wife in the 2023 Netflix
comedy you are so not invited to my bot
Mitzvah and a new collaboration with the
safties is also reportedly in
development all of this begs the
question will Sandler and Paul Thomas
Anderson ever team up again to a certain
extent they already have 2018 saw the
release of Sandler stand-up special 100%
fresh which was directed by longtime
Happy Madison director Steve Brill but
eagle-eyed fans may have caught Anderson
Manning a camera outside the theater
where the special was filmed he received
a special thanks and the end credits for
his efforts but anyone hoping for a more
official collaboration will have to
remain patient since 100% fresh Sandler
has kept up his break neck pace for
Netflix churning out two murder mystery
films and earning strong reviews for the
2022 basketball drama hustle Anderson
meanwhile wrote and directed 2021s
licorice pizza and has also directed
several music videos for an indie film
that made less than $30 million at the
box office punch drunk love has enjoyed
a remarkably long shelf life and Adam
Sandler sure sounds grateful for the
opportunity all those years ago while
promoting hustle in 2022 he told Yahoo
news it felt like a free gift from a guy
who called me up and said I wrote you a
movie when that happens it's incredible
he also credits the film with breaking
him out of his comfort zone and forcing
him to try something new as he admitted
to Cinema Blend in 2022 in my brain I
always thought yeah maybe one day I'll
do a different style of movie and
luckily Paul wrote that movie called me
up and said let's go if Sandler and
Anderson never officially collaborate
again maybe that's okay it's a well-worn
expression that the real meaning of
anything was the friends we made along
the way but in the case of punch drunk
love that really does seem to be true
Sandler is famously a gracious and
generous friend whether that means Bank
rolling starring vehicles for his Pals
or Penning a touching song about Chris
Farley for his 100% fresh special Punch
Drunk Love wasn't just an artistic
breakthrough it was also the beginning
of a decades long friendship as Sandler
admitted to Cinema Blend Paul's one of
my best buddies I love him so that's the
greatest thing that happened with that
movie Barry Ean was his pain was getting
a lot of
laughs
[Music]